hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play lone
survivor now we just got back into her
apartment after finding haha that this
guy's kind of crazy I've seen worse I do
me you do me I do me anyway I just
picked up a key outside of this mirror
here so I'm just filming that I'm gonna
use it um
oh no wait whoa whoa whoa there was a
hole that's right I gotta crawl in the
hole because why not huh why not I might
be able to squeeze through here
oh that's out again oh it's a food you
just ate you I need some more not
my favorite but it works
hey really well that's beef jerky salty
but solid guess is it was after me wait
I know I know what I need to do to get
besides I need to place rotting meat
here get in the hole real quickly and
then when I come back out we on the
other side munching on the dabit who's
smart though right it was smart
haha I'm getting hurt I'm probably
infected I'm probably already in fear
okay so that was really dumb I probably
didn't I have like uh lose this kind of
drug I think well before we just start
slamming down random pills let's uh not
okay I need to go to the right here well
maybe I could have shot it what kind of
idiot I of course I can shoot it I have
a gun
dumb no not that door anyway dark to
light on I need to find more BA to ease
was I have a gun let's try shooting in
know what you
hey wait a minute would you learn dance
for me hey he's just like wha what will
ya whoa what are you doing it my god
come on I love the way who stands like
hey bro oh hey whoa what you buddy what
you doing there is look whoa be careful
with that gun okay take a peek inside is
screw another goddamn hole I'll be
damned
damned if it in another damn hole I can
see you letterbox through just died
where's this one gonna take me who knows
oh it's moving hey there's more of those
meat chunks in here guess I can stock up
on meat chunks they may come in handy so
why is there just like a plethora of
rotting meat just laying everywhere I
mean I can understand why but look at
the skin skin looks like it's covering
another hole I guess I need something to
get through it maybe I I searched back
closer to home I marked this bleep on
the map or now you're living map I guess
also I get it
new batteries in why I don't have
batteries can of beans gal of beans
I remember Daisy I'll get killed all the
time just good know what you can of
beans
blam right in the face every time I
found a can of beans yeah I never
actually like Daisy all that much I
would have loved it if it wasn't so PvP
oriented I mean that's all Survivor but
I would like some more incentive to
cooperate as opposed to just steal from
your fellow man
um because I mean if I was in a survivor
Society you know there could be the
bandits and then there could be the
thing I would like to have like this
caste system where uh yeah the one
versus the other but you know that's not
this game I don't need to be talking
about that right now but I do need to be
talking about it was hiding from these
guys where is he
cool - yeah Danny monsters you guys
would let her come blue pill what in the
world does a blue pill do whoa for a
second there that looked like a face the
mouth down there on the crack and the
two eyes meathook the monsters through
here is dead I killed it
how do you know that oh is that oh
that's the other side I just went
through there okay oh oh there's always
another way oh there's always another
way that's right looks like there's a
hook there and a mail slot I could have
easily hung some meat there and got oh
okay
alright go from now and I'm gonna be
always looking for another way before I
just start shooting things damn it gotta
find another way around the black um I
guess if I go back home I can go through
the other way it seems to be the only
way to go I need to get to the mirror
and then go
yeah okay those flowers they're lovely
but why are they on the inside why are
they still growing okay where was the UH
was the mirror um it's in here that's
right there it is okay so if I go back
home I could use a bath but so I'm just
some little kid that's like stuck in
this hellhole of place okay so if I go
left
oh yeah hadn't locked it out damn it how
much was speaking back Oh
how am I supposed to be able to get back
okay looks like there's another
apartment
what is I think it was locked up me and
I'm not gonna do this I don't wait no
audience I don't even know Lucy here I
gotta find a way to get through the skin
that's what I gotta do go how do I do
that how do I do shoes these are mine
put in the code faded put been here a
long time I guess I need to find some
way to get through ah locked
need a key to the fire escape forget
that what to do I'm just gonna have to
explore out there for a little bit
before I go along my merry way
wait what did I not open this oh oh
that's right
I got the bedroom keeper here that's
weird
we're me and chage I being shy good more
an open I'm gonna try to avoid using it
from now on I got a box of pills read
the instructions might as well read the
red ones make you sharper the other ones
will make you duller being dull can help
you sleep especially if you run out of
what you need
just remember to weigh up the cost and
if you need more I'll leave some for you
in the bedroom
by the way you might find what you're
looking for in 205 and then there
recently and it's changed again it's not
signed at the bottom who's writing these
am i writing these okay so I need to go
to 205 might be important it probably is
important because it got nowhere else to
go anything and I'm mine I might not
mind well then whose are they did you
just steal this apartment you are drink
oh you killed everyone because that's
everyone's stuff
okay got more pills good I guess another
diary page let me read about them Larry
Page - okay wanted Dale stillness to
spread and to think they thought it was
me who was ill I'll show them their own
rotten insides I'll paint the damn walls
with their insights I'm tired of them
trying to attack me I'm gonna get out of
here kill anyone who tries to stop me I
found their weakness after all it's
there in their bony little knees okay
grey coats kind of crazy sounds like
something I don't want to meet cuz it's
you
I gotta go back to 205 you don't want to
sleep in that one will why not whoa the
stuff inside is not mine what is wrong
with you and things not being yours why
is it leaking I don't know where the
leak is coming from but that water's all
right well drink it then all right
anyway who's getting messed up man this
whole situation is like messed up beyond
all reason oh it's coming it's given is
it a coming I don't know if it's go even
different trick Billa into the she
arrows is here - coming can't tell I
can't see let me just do this I got a I
got huh huh I got plenty of hunks of
meat so place down in hi who did ya
hookah staff hello how's it going D
you're looking awfully svelte today
well then protein you're getting from
your died of pure meat they eat realize
there was one in you
how do I uh gotta get by him I probably
still shoot him
is it blam to plan me gloomy there
probably was another way but I didn't
have time
wait was here what what's this place
yeah I'm gonna blame you
Lambie what blam blam blam Oh
all right hmm there's something on it
can't open her finally I can open some
cans all right cool I needed that I'm
enough I would like flip might flip my
mind what my balls
rice pudding right on the dead body if
like this was all not reality there was
delicious ham inside can it still be
this fresh I could almost cry I've
dreamed about this for months
probably not bread um but if like at the
end of this it wasn't really an
infection and this guy was just kind of
crazy and was like just insane or
something something religious maybe I
can find anything all right so anyway
was this the door that was marked up no
other solution what eat sleep I will get
sleep soon man no the solution I wonder
who wrote it and why more to the point I
think maybe out of gas found some
schizos I can cut the skin away I guess
these could chop someone's head off or
skin off oh no the darkness is starting
to get to me I can't cope here oh no oh
oh I can't move the pain make it stop
it's a dictum pills man I'm gonna die
here wait no no no what what does that
abandon what whoa it's the Box head guy
from the beginning huh what happened all
I did was ran out of panties doctor man
who wears a box why are you wearing a
box for an in question that's a very
good question
hmm ho leave that for when you figured
that one for you to figure out okay ray
it looks like you're in need of help I
can be useful in my ways I wouldn't
spend too long creeping around sleep is
comfortless if you're hungry
if you need to see me again take the
green pill Thank You mr. box man
something extra in my backpack a couple
batteries in there is there someone out
there trying to help me the guardian
angel maybe oh I'm so confused my
stomach is growling well we'll eat what
right before we have time to sleep
because they said something about sleep
is only comforting you need to eat okay
so this thing is still out here or at
least I should be I shouldn't waste my
batteries as one of I should be getting
it place that down meat down hide in the
shadows just like Assassin's Creed
except net I wish I had a knife or
something it would be useful on those
things okay back
I'm in 206 all right back in here need
to find the rest of what's going on here
barely see some new batteries and don't
run out man okay there's a hole this is
it the only one in the holy woman never
go back in there okay that is the hole
that I went in does that mean that I
went in all these before baby okay right
then this okay Plus this is where I
collapsed but okay never mind I'm a
guest no I don't need to use this I need
to definitely ration that like a lot
I've been in here I've been in here I
don't need anything okay I died okay
what I need to do is I need to get back
to the skin I'm wasting time Oh God
kind of person just visit I need to get
back to the skin you know no you know
wait how did I get out of here no way no
no no no no no no hungry all right we'll
eat something man but not the delicious
ham I say that if you orange is risky
tasted oddly fresh well good for me then
I guess I'm not gonna die oh crap
let me get around this one
what do I do ah okay there was hiding
it's not it's kind of hard to see the
hiding places I want to get asking but
sometimes there's like indentations in
the wall that I can't quite see mr.
jewel for but the numbers been removed
and it's locked and maybe that'll change
later because this guy is super psycho
bonkers okay destroyed ladder blah blah
blah carrying on okay good back into
here and then we're gonna go we're
through here then into this hole through
this cupboard and cut the skin and we're
gonna be good cut oh man do I really
want have to go through with this I
don't know oh well now I feel bit unwell
you feel unwell oh oh yeah yeah yeah oh
okay there's one to the right there in
the darkness where am I now
oh good can't open it must be broken
that's not though I'm uh oh okay well
that's useful all right then there's
better be no more monsters in there I
bet there's lots but there's this
poodles oh is that a battery
no it's can of soda give it turn it off
and it often enough
who's that what does that sound I'll
play the drums over there okay all right
there's another mirror here that means I
can choose to go home if I wanted to
well I don't think I need sleep right
now but I'm kidding kind of oh man I
want to play more oh no I got to take
this opportunity here I think I need
sleep and right now I don't think I'm
hungry so I feel beer all right I must
save and then it's gonna be into this
episode all right damn it
oh man I'm into this game I'm into this
game deep I need that I know you did man
I know you did I'm here for you whatever
your name is draco malfoy
okay so anyway this game is awesome I am
having a blast playing and I can't wait
to play more so thank you all so much
for watching click the annotation for
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video bye
okay
Oh God
I got
blue purple blue purple